[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein richtig cooles rezept
und zwar machen wir eine lasagne aus dem
backofen mit spinat und lachs und einer
tomaten rahmsauce wir haben nämlich
gerade eine torte gebacken und jetzt
haben wir beim dreh hunger bekommen und
jetzt gibt's die lasagne
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal die
zutaten für die tomatensoße die bereitet
nämlich zuallererst dafür brauche ich
etwas olivenöl eine zwiebel und 3
knoblauchzehen etwas zucker jetzt nicht
gramm mehl 400 gramm tomaten aus der
dose jeweils 150 milliliter gemüsebrühe
sahne und milch und etwas parmesan jetzt
nämlich zuerst einmal die zwiebeln und
die knoblauchzehe und die werden ganz
fein gewürfelt und das macht jetzt
entweder mit einem messer oder mit
schiffen
die alligators aussies
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich das olivenöl in einem
kleinen topf erhitzen und den zwiebel
und knoblauch würfel darin anbraten das
dauert drei bis vier minuten
[Musik]
zum binden brauche ich jetzt ein
bisschen mehl wird so eine art bei amen
soße
das kommt jetzt hier mit reifen wird
einfach ein bisschen noch eingerührt
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die mischung
ablöschen mit dem tomaten aus der dose
der gemüsebrühe und auch mit der sahne
[ __ ] kommt dann noch eine prise
zucker rhein könnte auch ein
würfelzucker nehmen um das ganze muss
jetzt aufgekauft und dann eingekocht
werden also so etwa fünf minuten
und jetzt schmecke ich gemalt gleich ab
salz und pfeffer kommt natürlich auch
dazu und dann könnt ihr nach wunsch zum
beispiel ein bisschen oregano zufügen
oder auch basilikum je nachdem in welche
richtung er gehen möchte
aber das lassen wir jetzt hier erst
einmal ganz kurz aufkochen und ich kann
ihn derzeit nichts taugen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die soße ist jetzt soweit und ich zeige
euch noch die zutaten die ich außerdem
brauche ich brauche 600 gramm lachsfilet
entweder frisch oder ihm den aus dem
tiefkühlfach 500 gramm lasagne platten
200 gramm cocktailtomaten etwas parmesan
und cavalese also cash ein kilo spinat
auch entweder frisch oder aus dem
tiefkühlfach und dann noch salz pfeffer
und etwas muskat
jetzt kann ich zuerst einmal den lachs
nehmen und den habe ich auch eigentlich
immer vorrätig da
den habe ich jetzt schon auf trauen
lassen und schneidet ihnen einfach korb
in würfel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kann ich schon mal den parmesan
reiben und einteilt brauche ich ja für
innen rein und ein teil für obendrauf
[Musik]
so da war ich auch schön weg miteinander
malerei begeht das gericht muss ich
vorher noch die finger jetzt noch den
cut käse
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die lasagne schon
schichten dafür nämlich eine auflaufform
da kommt etwas olivenöl rein
[Musik]
ich geb unten immer gerne ein bisschen
soße rein dann wenige blätter ich habe
mich eine person habe
wieder etwas sauce und jetzt kommen hier
die lachse stücke mit rein gemeinsam mit
dem spinat und den spinat in habe ich
jetzt auch auftauen lassen und die
flüssigkeit einfach ein bisschen
ausgedrückt und den wird sich jetzt noch
mit muskat salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da kommt jetzt etwas parmesan rein und
dann die nächste schicht ich mache jetzt
insgesamt einfach drei schichten
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die nächste bzw letzten
schicht also mehr geht echt nicht trotz
fällt sowieso zusammen da jetzt noch ein
bisschen was von der soße
[Musik]
und hier kommen jetzt noch die tomaten
drauf und die könnte jetzt entweder
halbieren oder zum beispiel auch
vierteln
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt hier noch die parmesan
und café keese mischung drauf und
cassatt ist wirklich super weil er ganz
toll schmilzt also eine tonne schmelz
eigenschaft hat und der parmesan bringen
so ein bisschen mehr geschmack mit rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kann die lasagne schon in den
backofen
[Musik]
das ist so schön da wird sich eine
freundin freunde ja ist erster platz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
levrat oder so ich glaube diese kommen
wie lachs und spinat kennt jeder
mit tomate voll lecker und mir gefallen
vor allem die farben von dem gerücht
lachs über alles für dich jetzt wohl
schneller ich habe hunger
ich habe so ein loch in meinem bauch so
groß ist oft wo und mit dieser rahmen
sind ehrlich ganz ehrlich bitte bitte
macht gott sei dank da machen das ganz
schnell ich nehme das jetzt hier wenn
ihr das nachmachen wollen sie geht
einfach auf meinem blog auf sally hunger
zum rheinsteig ja noch weiter erzählen
machst du denn schluss bitte für mich
und ich gehe jetzt erstmal ein billiger
bauen jetzt da und das thema komme es
gibt mittagessen mein gott werden alles
ist okay und es war so einfach unser
schnell und genial einfach nur genial
wird lässt wieder sind es ist es lösen
essen
[Musik]
[Applaus]